This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Do and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
four post-doates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
Ruth, let's do it.
>> Hello and welcome everyone.
Let's go ahead and open up that Zoom
room door and let everybody in. My name
is Ruth Ellen Sanchez. I am
going to be your hostess today for
dailywithdoc and becca which is
sponsored by dailywithdoc.com
and this program is for educational
purposes only and not meant to treat
diagnose or cure any diseases and it's
not meant to take the place of your
primary care physician. Also, any
testimonials given will be experiences
of the person giving the testimonial.
And
I think I covered it all. And today we
are excited to have pharmacist Ben
Buuches
and he is a highly experienced
registered pharmacist with over 40 years
of practic practice. Ben holds a BA in
broadcast journalism and from Syracuse
University and a bachelor of science in
pharmacy from the University of
Colorado. He's also a compound
pharmacist and he specializes in
creating custom medications particularly
for the skin health. He also is an
expert in formulating nutritional
products and has spent years consulting
with doctors and patients to optimize
their health. Ben is very passionate
about
using natural approaches for health. He
believes in the body's inherent ability
to heal and regenerate itself.
By providing with it with the right
nutrition nutrients, we can optimize our
health and well-being.
And I think that God created some
amazing
things.
Our bodies can heal themselves. And um
I'm just always in awe of our body's
um ability to do that.
So, I am gonna bring on Ben, who is
amazing. And we've got a really good
topic today.
Are you excited about these Rolling
Stones and the metabolic syndrome, Ben?
>> Rolling Stones. I don't know what that
means, but check this out. The dose
makes the medicine.
>> Yes.
>> Don't ever forget that. Dose makes the
medicine. Got to have enough of the good
stuff. So, uh, we're Ruthan, I guess you
would you or under ordinary
circumstances, Becca would be throwing
stuff at me, but I'll just take it away
on met unless you have questions.
>> I do have questions, but we did have a
topic if you wanted to do the topic or
we could go right to questions.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, if you have something
I like talking about metabolic syndrome.
I sent D I sent um AJ something during
the week as I do typically. I I think AJ
was on was on metabolic syndrome and
cancer. I think it was
>> I don't know. I did send you the topic
on your cell phone.
>> Yeah. So, let's talk about metabolic
syndrome. I used I used to call it it
used to be called syndrome X before then
at first. Then it was called insulin
resistance. Now we call it metabolic
syndrome. The word syndrome refers to
many many symptoms that come from one
cause. Metabolic syndrome involves a lot
of different things. Basically metabolic
syndrome is not really one disease. It's
a cluster of metabolic abnormalities.
These kinds of abnormalities occur
together most commonly and they include
things like obesity,
um insulin resistance, high blood
pressure, uh changes in blood fats and
atherogenesis that is uh uh clogs,
clots, clots, uh not clots, blockages,
not clots but blockages,
atherosclerosis,
heart attacks, strokes, vascular
disease, type 2 diabetes most especially
Where do you hear about all these
things? That's all the stuff we suffer
from and throw cancer into the mix mix,
too. Pretty much everything we deal with
from a chronic degenerative disease
crisis has this this u constellation of
symptoms associated with metabolic
syndrome behind it. I call it the second
point on the triangle of disease there.
And I want to be very clear here.
There's no chronic degenerative disease
that occurs without metabolic syndrome
underneath. And by the way, without
digestive issues underneath. This is
where I came up with the triangle
concept which has now been truncated to
the to the plane concept or the line
concept because the third element just
complicates things. The adrenal thyroid,
right? Uh adrenal thyroid length. So you
get diagnosed with metabolic syndrome
which by the way is a very interesting
word because metabolism is the sum total
of chemical reactions in the body.
So, you might as well say everything
does everything syndrome. Metabolic
syndrome is everything. It's kind of a
crazy name because you it's just
everything that could go wrong.
Everything that could possibly go wrong
can go wrong when you have metabolic
syndrome. The diagnosis for metabolic
syndrome involves technically three of
um the following criteria. There's
weight uh issues uh uh waist
circumference I should say uh
cholesterol issues high blood sugar high
uh high blood sugar uh blood pressure
issues abdominal fat uh changes in blood
fats uh and increased vascular pressure
associated with hypertension. All of
those are the core diagnoses for
metabolic syndrome. And metabolic
syndrome doubles your risks of heart
disease and cancer and autoimmune
diseases and everything else, which is
so cool because what it means is you can
reduce your risk dramatically, maybe
even eliminate them by one small move.
Now, small move isn't necessarily easy,
but it's simple. And that means reducing
your blood sugar and lowering your
insulin. And they go together. And
unfortunately, uh, we lump the two. They
go together, but they're separate
issues. And unfortunately, we conflate
the two. When people go to the doctor,
they never get their insulin check. They
always get their blood sugar checked
because insulin is almost impossible to
check because it always fluctuates. And
plus, it's in the blood in very small
concentrations. So, the major feature of
metabolic syndrome is insulin
resistance. But here's where it gets
tricky. Insulin resistance itself and
blood sugar issues are linked to the
digestive system. And so if you have
digestive issues, liver issues,
pancreatic issues, most especially
intestinal issues, and bile issues,
you're also at higher risk for
um for metabolic syndrome. And that in
like I say, includes everything. And
there's nothing there's no medications
that you can do to really address
metabolic syndrome above and beyond the
symptoms of metabolic syndrome. So,
for the life of me, I can't figure out
why we still have these questions. I can
see why it's hard to do. And make no
mistake about it, I'm in it. I I have
find it hard to do also. In other words,
to control your blood sugar and to eat
foods that don't spike your blood sugar
because we're hardwired to do that kind
of stuff. But it's it's not complicated.
So if you have a weight problem,
metabolic syndrome. If you have a
vascular problem, high blood pressure,
cardiovascular problem, metabolic
syndrome. If you have a thyroid problem,
metabolic syndrome. If you have
autoimmune diseases, metabolic syndrome.
God forbid cancer, metabolic syndrome.
You can't work on cancer and heart
disease and hypothyroidism, etc. on
their own, but you can by working on
metabolic syndrome first. and the
digestive system second. Simple as that
or easy as that. Simple as that.
Although it's not necessarily easy. So
if you have questions about anything,
I'll answer them, but I'm always going
to talk about metabolic syndrome and the
digestive system. It's the darn triangle
or now the plane of disease. Okay. Does
that make sense? You have questions
there?
>> Yes, I have questions. Um
>> Rebecca sent me a question.
>> Yeah.
>> For you. Um, hi Rebecca.
>> Yes. Hello, Rebecca.
I forgot to give her a shout out. So,
shout out to you, Rebecca. We love you.
Um, she has a question. It says, "I have
a qu a teen boy who's in the bathroom 45
minutes at a time. The medical doctor,
give me one second. I got to move this.
Took X-rays revealing he's holding
excess poop in his colon. We did a
radical the radical amazing amount of
mirillax and xlax to get things moving.
I have the yi 90 for life enzymes,
probiotics, etc., etc. Even the true to
life detox tea that just doesn't seem to
make a difference.
>> He still can't seem to go to eliminate
in a timely fashion. And then she wants
to know what's going on. And um
>> is there a help?
>> Yeah, of course there is. So here's the
thing. She's addressing the stool, but
she's not addressing the intestine. All
those things, Mirax and Xlax and fiber
and the mighty 90 and all the things she
just talked about that addresses the
stool. First of all, backtrack a little
bit. The kids constipated. So they have
an X-ray and the doctor says, "Oh, your
kid's constipated." This is how idiotic
our our this is just the idiocy of our
medical model and of us as patients
because we go to these non you know we
participate in it. So what did he tell
what what good did he do? He says I know
you know there's this comedian Brian
Reagan. He says I went to the doctor and
um I told him I had a little heartburn.
The doctor gave him a list and said
here's all the things that cause
heartburn. And the Brian Reagan says I
know what causes heartburn. What do I do
about it? I could get heartburn. I got
heartburn. what do I do about it? It's
like you go to these people and they
tell you what you got. I don't care. I
want to know what I can do about it. But
it doesn't matter because we can do it
ourselves. So, um, first of all,
constipation should always be regarded
as a food issue. That's the first thing.
And by that I mean the body kind of the
intestine kind of freezes up in response
to certain foods. So, food diary is very
important. in an emergency and it could
be an emergency when you have really
clogged up for a long time. Colonics can
be helpful and you know what a colonic
is. They put water up there and they
wash everything out. Okay, so that
that's kind of like an emergency
procedure that you can do. But first of
all, from a long-term perspective, you
want to focus on specific foods that the
patient's eating.
>> Third uh thirdly,
Bob Ross triangulation. Look for other
symptoms. These will give you clues on
what what is happening in the body
systemically. Does the kid tired? Is the
kid have acne or other skin problems?
Does he bloat after certain foods? Does
his pulse race after certain foods or
heart rate, heart race after certain
foods? Look for other symptoms. Is there
heartburn, etc. And then map them in a
food diary and associate them with
foods. Point number three. So, um, you
know, you could do the colonics if you
want. You can look for problem foods if
you want. Not if you want. Colonics for
emergency. Look for problem foods. Do a
food diary and associate them with other
symptoms so you can triangulate and get
and get a big picture of what's
happening in the body. But here's the
main issue that I wanted to bring up.
The way food is food is processed
through the digestive tract and then
eliminated out of the bowels involves
the nervous system and the muscular
system.
We know that there's a disease caused by
a major neural and musc neural
activating vitamin which AJ loves called
berry berry. I can't I can't and this is
usually associated with an inability to
move the body. However, you can have GI
berry berry that is digestive tract
berry berry where under deficiencies of
vitamin B1 thamin that's the berry berry
vitamin you um your muscles the the
neuromuscular
um wiring in the intestine slows down.
And so anybody out there who's dealing
with chronic long-term uh constipation
and can't figure out why, in addition to
the food diary, in addition to looking
for other symptoms, in addition to
colonics, start using high doses of
vitamin B1. Beyond Tangy Tangerine is
your best friend in that regard. By the
way, Ruth Ellen, do you know how to be a
good Do you know what vitamin What
vitamin helps you be a good friend?
>> Which one?
>> Vitamin B1.
>> B1. Yes.
It's very key. Yeah. And also
>> so but let me let me just say one more
thing here about chronic constipation.
Another thing and I'm not just talking
about this kid. So when I talk about
vitamin B1 high doses, when I talk about
food diary, when I talk about
eliminating problem uh food diary and
eliminating problem foods, uh when we
talk about um colonics, uh in addition,
it has to be recognized that the more
you eat, the more sluggish your
digestive tract will be, especially if
you're eating all day long because the
digestive tract slows down when there's
food in it so the body can extract
nutrition. So, if you're snacking and
eating foods all day long, you're going
to uh the bowel will be less active.
It'll be more sluggish than when you
fast. So, another strategy is to stop
eating. Don't eat for a day or two days.
And that will tend to have a bowel
evacuating benefit. So, you got
colonics, you've got food diaries,
you've got eliminating problem foods,
you've got vitamin B1, and you've got
calorie restriction or or fasting more
exactly than calorie restriction.
>> Okay. about what he's drinking too
because um you know a lot of soda so
dehydration would be
>> dehydration is another factor as well
and also um probiotics if you don't have
enough bacteria so probiotics are
another important strategy I would get
on all the digestive support supplements
but I'd want to know what else is going
on in his body want to know about all
these other symptoms particularly skin
symptoms and also digestive symptoms and
also what's going what's going on with
the foods it's unusual
for a kid to have these problems. So
that tells us a couple things because
this is a sort of degenerative
condition. And so usually if you're old
or older, I mean there's a lot of stuff
going on. So it's a lot harder to find
exactly what the problem is. But when
somebody's a kid, it's much easier
because there's not a lot of stuff going
on. He hasn't really been breaking down
for a long time. So if he does have this
problem, the other symptoms are going to
be more dramatic. They're not going to
be subtle. he's going to notice other
symptoms more dramatic. So, is it if
it's someone that that Rebecca knows,
start asking questions. If there's
weight problems, you can pretty much
pretty much rest assured there's
metabolic syndrome. And by the way, let
me just say one last thing about
metabolic syndrome. Metabolic syndrome
implies
systemic inflammation. Metabolic
syndrome is known as insulin resistance
syndrome, which the cells stop listening
to insulin. One of the main reasons is
is because when insulin is constantly
high, you're eating a lot of sugar,
you're eating a lot of insulin spiking
foods, the cells kind of turn down the
dial on on the listening, they turn down
their hearing aid, their receptors, you
can think of like ears, they turn down
the receptors. However, inflammation in
the blood which comes from the digestive
tract will also tend towards um will
also lead towards uh insulin resistance.
So systemic inflammation is also
involved and that's the digestive tract
for metabolic syndrome. So there could
be some metabolic syndrome issues for
this kid as well and I'd be looking at
that too.
>> Okay. Thank you. And AJ, you have your
hand up, so I'm going to bring you on.
>> Two questions. Pharmacist Ben, how are
you today?
>> I'm good. Thank you. AJ, good to see
you.
>> Good to see you as well. My two
questions are number one
um does this metabolic syndrome also uh
count for eye issues
>> AJ
my lips everything
>> everything
>> everything from from losing the hair on
your head to having toenail fungus head
to toe everything.
So my glaucoma is partly due to his
metabolic syndrome.
>> Your glaucoma?
>> No.
>> Yes. Your glaucoma or whoever's glaucoma
is not partially due. It's intimately
linked.
>> Intimately linked.
>> Intimately linked. And I know you know
I'm teasing you a little bit. We said
does it mean my eye issues? And I know
you were probably asking for for the
listeners, but it's really important
because when we say everything, people
will say, "What about my thyroid?"
Everything. Oh, what about my myinia
gravis? Everything. What about my
retinitis pigmentotosa? Everything. And
and there's a philosophical idea here
that we a historical philosophical idea
here that we got to kind of address.
Historically, the medical model that is
pitted against us.
Remember the institution is always
against the individual. Institutions are
there for themselves, not for the
individual. And they don't move.
Individuals have to move fast because
they get cancer and their kids get sick
and they can go broke and they can lose
their house. Institutions don't have
that problem. So institutions are very
very slow. They don't move fast at all.
The word stits in institution means
static stays the same.
>> So institutions are by their definition
by definition there to stay the same.
>> So the institution of medicine has been
stagnant philosophically since the days
of the enlightenment. the high middle
ages about 500 years ago, 600 years ago.
And this medical model that has that
that has stayed stagnant for 600 years
is based on this reductionistic idea
that the body is made up of individual
components.
The heart, the skin, the liver, the
bones, the digestive system, the
reproductive system, the nervous system,
etc.
That's why when you have a skin problem,
you go to the dermatologist. You have a
heart problem, you go to the
cardiologist. You got a a brain problem,
you go to the neurologist. You got a
bone problem, you go to the osteopath or
the I forgot what they call the bone
doctor. You go to the bone doctor guy.
OBGYn for female health issu issues. The
um whatever, think of some other ones.
the immunologist if you have immune
problems,
>> nefologist,
>> nephologist for kidney problems, etc.
That's not how the body works. The body
is a system
and it's made up of just a couple of
systems. Digestive system, point number
one, the metabolic system, point number
two, are the main systems. You can throw
in the the adrenal thyroid system and
that's been pretty much it. But there's
no metabolic system doctor. There's no
digestive system doctor. There's GI
doctors, but they don't link it to the
system. This is all based on a concept
called systems theory. Systems theory is
a really it's how computers the computer
business started or the computer the
science of um information processing
started in the 1940s. And it posits that
systems have their own way of operating.
And until we understand that the body is
a system made of a bunch of made up of a
b interconnecting parts, we're not going
to be able to take care of and we're not
going to be able to address things
because when you have a heart problem,
it's not a heart problem. It's a systems
problem. And that's why cardiology can
do nothing for people have heart heart
problems except mechanic. They can kind
of reroute things with a bypass or they
could poison systems with, you know,
statin drugs or beta blockers or cardiac
or calcium channel blockers. They can
kind of shut down symptoms, but they
can't address systems. The body's a
system. This accounts for the failure.
It's not because they're dumb. It's not
because they're murderers. It's not
because they're evil. It's that they're
basing their ideas on a an old notion
that the body can be treated as a heart
and a lung and a spleen and an intestine
rather than an entire system. How you
can't go to a doctor for the system.
There's no systems doctors. However, the
beautiful thing about systems, the body
system, is we can do it ourselves. And
the classic example
to prove this to yourself is to fast.
Because when you fast you and stop
putting things into the body, the system
stands down and now it can do its work
without interference. Now obviously you
have to eat again so you can't fast
forever. But fasting will demonstrate to
you visibly how the system takes care of
itself. It rebalances itself as soon as
there's no more input coming in. As soon
as you stop the stream of input, the
system will re-calibrate. And that's the
beauty of the system. We always say the
body heals itself. That's what we mean.
Homeostatic balancing mechanisms will
kick in to readjust and re-calibrate the
system. As soon as input stops, but if
you're chronically inputting, the system
doesn't have a chance to recalibrate.
It's spending its time trying to
incorporate what you're putting into the
body, what you what you're putting into
the system. What you want to do is you
want to stop that input so then the body
can recalibrate. And by the way,
mentally,
this is where something called stillness
comes in. Bible says, "Be still and know
that I am God." Right? What that means
is as long as there's noise, you're not
going to be able to feel any of the
divinity. You're not going to feel any
of the spirituality, any of the magic
that's in the world because you're going
to be busy incorporating all the stuff
that's that's streaming into your your
mental system, all the information
that's streaming into your mental
system. But as soon as you stop, the
system will recalibrate. It'll stabilize
and you'll see how divine and how
spiritual the world really is. Be still
and know that I'm God. From a physical
perspective, that means not eating. From
a physical perspective, be still and the
body will adjust itself and it will run.
As long as you have all your parts, you
have all your nutrition, it'll run
pristinely on its own. Yes.
>> Okay. Well, you you you you brought up a
couple uh things that would make me want
to ask a further question. I do
understand the concept because I've been
following you for some time now, but as
far as when people have rolling stones
in their kidneys,
>> okay,
>> in their kidneys or or gallbladder,
how how can we u attack them knowing
that it's a system that we need to
repair?
How do we attack the the rolling stones?
How
>> Yeah. How do we how do we deal with the
kidney stones and the liver stone and
the um gall and the gallstones? How do
we deal with those?
>> Okay. Okay. How do you deal them?
>> As a as a particular question that
prompted the title,
>> you go back the way it came you came.
You go backwards. You work backwards.
How do stones get formed? I mean, you
need to that's why I always ask about
mech. That's why I always talk about
mechanisms and that's why any time
somebody asks me about you know a
product or a drug or even a supplement I
want to talk about the mechanism how it
works the mechanism is the key
mechanisms is an engineering idea and
that's really the way you want to look
at the body as an engineering an
engineered system it's and the best
place to go for advice about how the
body works is an engineer a biological
engineer if you will or a biochemist,
not a doctor. A doctor is not the best
place to go because a doctor just wants
to get you symptom free. Whatever it
takes. That's his mission is to get you
symptom free. A doctor's there so you
don't die. If you're satisfied with not
dying, if that's good enough for you,
have at it. But if you want to thrive,
you've got to understand how breakdown
occurs, how pathology occurs. So what
are stones? Let's take gallstones for
example. Okay, but it's true about any
stone, but let's take gallstones. What
are stones? Stones are solid material
that that are showing up in a part of
the body that's ordinarily fluid.
Okay? So gall stones are showing up in
the bile. Bile is usually a fluid, but
the stones form. So there's a
relationship between the liquid and the
solid. The bile and the stone. Liquid
and the solid, right?
>> Yes.
>> What would cause a stone? It's true
about tear duct stones or kidney stones
or bladder stones or any other any other
kind of stones you have. What would
cause a solid to form in a liquid?
Well,
>> oversaturation.
>> That's one of the main things, but and
that's very important. But what would
cause saturation? Oversaturation.
The millu
of the fluid
plays a role on how soluble
the solid is. So if I have a cup of
water
and I put salt in it, the salt will go
in. Like we've said many times, a little
bit goes in, a little bit goes in, a
little bit goes in, and then all of a
sudden you put one little more, one
grain of salt or one small amount of
salt, the whole thing precipitates. It
becomes, as DJ said, super saturated.
But that super saturation
will be more
or less
likely to occur depending on the pH of
the water, the heat of the water, the
other solids that are in the water. In
other words, the millu of the water is
going to play a role in how fast
the salt super saturates. Does that make
sense?
>> Yes.
>> So, what is the millu in terms of the
bile or in terms of the fluid system?
The pH is the most important also the
acid level, the oxygen level, the other
factors that are in the blood. But the
most important, the probably the closest
in relevance is going to be the acidity
of the bile or the fluid level. What I'm
saying is it's the environment that the
stones are forming in that is playing
the role in whether the sto stones form
or not. If you go to the doctor, they're
going to target the stones and for good
reason because they can be miserably
painful.
But if you want to prevent the stones,
you have to manipulate the environment
the stones are in. And this is a
fundamental truth in alternative
medicine that orthodox medicine doesn't
recognize. And this is a a great battle
in the world between alternative and
orthodox medicine between the terrain
and the particle.
In other words, the terrain is the
environment
and the particle is what's forms in the
environment. Doctors are always focusing
on the particle. We as alternate
practitioners have strength over the
terrain. In terms of bile, it means
changing the way bile the the liquid
nature of bile, changing the way the
bacteria in the intestine interact with
the bile, changing the um the the the
thickness of the bile by controlling the
kinds of foods that you're eating. So we
have this is where we have control.
Doctors can't do anything about stones.
They can you know surgically surgically
repair remove the gallbladder or they
can shoot u sound waves at the stones
but they can't change the terrain. The
terrain is a function of our lifestyle.
And so we want to work on our lifesty.
That's what the whole mission is here.
The whole game is to work on the terrain
by manipulating your lifestyle. Even
something as simple as breathing oxygen
can help liquefy the fluid portion of
the body, particularly the blood. Not
necessarily bile, but particularly the
blood. If you have a bile problem, you
want to treat it as a food problem.
Everything, everywhere you can go or
every symptom you can name,
figure out how it associates with the
triangle of disease. Everyone.
Everyone. And you know when I start
doing my talks I always say there's one
thing you need if you want to play this
game of correcting health challenges or
or maintaining your health.
There's only one thing you need or no
there's there's only one thing you need
at first. You got to do other things too
but there's one thing you need at first.
What's the first thing you need? It's
not beyond dang tangerine. What's the
first thing you need?
>> Awareness.
>> Close. Belief.
>> Belief. You got to believe.
You got to believe it's true. What I'm
saying, yeah, there's people nodding
their heads. Yeah, it makes sense. It
makes sense. But when push comes to
shove, when you have a gall stone or
kidney stone or a heart blockage, do you
believe that it's a triangle of disease?
Do you believe that the body's a
homeostatic system that can adjust
itself? Do you believe that you or me,
whoever is incurring the problem, is
responsible?
>> I believe.
>> Okay, there you go. It's about belief.
>> No, but I'm with you 150%.
>> It's about belief.
>> And and pharmacist Ben, you know, um I'm
asking the question, but I have notes of
you mentioning that people need to
liquefy the body, liquefy the blood by
drinking water when they first wake up.
You've mentioned using the mighty 90 to
help the pH. You've mentioned using your
ultimate enzymes,
uh you know, So, you've mentioned a
number of things that we can do, but I
am asking because I want the people to
hear you say.
>> Yes, I got that. And I know you know the
stuff and and you know, AJ, props to
you. I've never met anybody in longevity
who's a lay person who knows knows as
much as you and who learns as much as
you. And I really
>> You hear that, Phyllis and Albert? And
you hear that?
>> Nobody. Everybody else. I'm not no knock
on everybody.
>> I'm not knocking anybody else.
>> You are dude. AJ, you are a a rock star
for a lay person. I mean, AJ's ability
to absorb information, retain
information, understand everything I'm
saying.
>> A1 nobody.
>> He's amazing.
>> Really really amazing. Really amazing.
I'm proud to be associated with you, AJ.
Honestly, that's that's
>> I'm honored to be associated with all of
you.
>> Okay. All right. And I love everybody
else, too. That's no knock, but special
props to AJ.
>> Yes. Of course. Go ahead. So Mary is
bringing in some questions from YouTube,
I believe. So Mary,
>> that's correct. Can you hear me?
>> I hear you. Hi, Mary.
>> Perfect. Hey, uh, couple of questions
from YouTube. Now, I'm going to do one
from, uh, Cindy, but I'm going to
preface it that we do have the triangle
of disease.com.
So, there's additional information on
there, but Cindy has asked the question.
She's looking for an explanation like
you're talking to a firstear junior high
student.
>> Okay.
>> And she wants to have an explanation of
the triangle as we continue to talk
about. So, she wants to know what is the
triangle. Okay. Fair enough. Ask about
diary. So, she's trying to get it in a
simple form.
>> I got it. I got it.
So, I have to say I am guilty of like
talking about things like everybody
knows. That's because we talk about them
all the time, but I'm guilty of not
recognizing there's new people who may
not have heard these ideas. Mia culp on
that. I'm also guilty of not taking
advantage of the idea that repetition is
reinforcement. And the more you repeat
something, the more you reinforce it and
that's always valuable. So, mia on that.
So, let's talk about the triangle of
disease. Okay.
many years ago
almost 20 now even longer I noticed that
when people had health challenges
because people come to me with health
challenges that there were these basic
things that everything that happened
that they all had they all had these
basic ideas and the more I started to
explore the more I saw that they were
all interconnected almost everybody not
almost every everybody
who had a chronic degenerative condition
and that's we should probably digress
there real quickly Because chronic
degenerative diseases are the bulk of
our health problems as opposed to
getting hit by a car or having a major
infection. Those are those are not
chronic and degenerative. Chronic means
long-term. Degenerative means you
degenerate. You don't repair. The repair
system that we're always talking about
doesn't happen. Instead of regenerating,
you degenerate. And I noticed that
people had these chronic degenerative
conditions, which is the vast majority
of our health challenges. They always
had digestive problems.
And then I noticed they always had blood
sugar issues. And then I noticed they
always had cortisol issues. And then I
noticed they also had hypothyroidism.
And the more I saw, the more I looked
and the more I explored, I saw that
there was a a sequential link. One led
to the other led to the other. And at
the top of the the the se sequence, if
you will, which is three points. That's
why I call it the triangle. the top of
the sequence
you fed back to the first two points of
the triangle. So everybody had digestive
issues, everybody had blood sugar
issues, everybody had adrenal thyroid
issues. And from the adrenal thyroid
issues, you get more metabol more blood
sugar more digestive issues and more
metabolic issues which lead to more
adrenal thyroid issues and you get this
downward spiral. And I noticed this and
the more I started to explore I saw how
logical it was when we're born
from the vast majority of us. We are not
treated how from a h we are not treated
effectively or appropriately from a
digestive system perspective. This
starts at birth for many people because
30% of people come to Syrian section and
that deprivives them of of the bacteria
that are they're supposed to get as they
pass through the mother's birth canal
and out the uh through a vaginal birth.
When a baby's born, as many moms know
out there vaginally, they're coated with
bacteria. Those bacteria go into the
baby's mouth and into the baby's nose
and they they implant in the baby's um
digestive tract. And from that point
forward, they help the baby process
food.
Off the bat don't get that. 30% of
babies right off the bat don't get that.
And probably more when we're talking
about people our age. I'm 66. So people
our age probably even more. Right? So
we're we're dealing with millions of
people who right from the get-go, right
from the day they're born begin the pro
the digestive system begin digestive
system issues. And we see this with
collic, with rashes, with baby
heartburn, with pro bowel problems and
gases and bloating and discomfort in
babies. We see it all the time.
Now, if you're not breastfed,
that's even worse because now you're not
getting the basic building blocks for
the for the intestine. Now, and to feed
the bacteria, now you're depending on
formula, which is especially problematic
for the digestive system.
So, right from the get-go, 30, 40, 50,
maybe more percent of babies are
compromised at the level of the
digestive system. Then you throw in the
baby food and the popsicles and the
apple juice and the distorted food
supply uh foods in the food supply, the
the oils, you know, formula is largely
made up of processed oils, seed oils. So
you you've got this situation where the
digestive tract is completely whacked
out for most kids by the time they're
two or three years old, unless the
parent really knows what they're doing,
which is rare, but for most of us, our
parents didn't know what they were
doing. So now you've got a situation
where by the time the kid is two or
three or four years old, his digestive
system is whacked out. This, of course,
leads to blood problems
because we know that toxins get into the
bloodstream. This causes a condition of
systemic inflammation.
the body becomes inflamed. That systemic
inflammation makes it difficult for the
body to respond to sugar and to insulin
appropriately.
In uh inflammation disturbs insulin, a
metabolic insulin pro insulin um the
work of insulin.
>> Elevated blood sugar compounds the
problem. Look what kids are eating. Look
at all the sugar sugary foods kids are
eating. So now you got a kid, he's 2,
three, four, five years old and he's
already got digestive distress,
digestive disturbances. It's tumbled
into uh uh disturbed blood. I call it
dirty blood, which leads to inflammatory
problems, which leads to insulin uh
insulin signaling problems. Cells don't
listen to insulin in the presence of all
these inflammatory factors. You're
pounding the system with sugar, putting
more load on the insulin system. This
completely whacks out the metabolic
process. Metabolic means the way we get
energy. So now you got a kid, he's six,
seven, eight, nine, 10 years old and
he's already starting to show up with
juvenile diabetes and autoimmune
problems and and chronic fatigue and
skin problems and all the things our
kids are suffering from. Obesity,
childhood obesity. And because we're not
seeing these two points on the trial
disease, we don't know what to do. We go
to the doctor. They give him drugs. They
tell him to exercise more. You know,
they give him all the the standard
medical kinds of u shibilis and jargon
and and slogans that they're supposed to
do. And nobody is participating.
Nobody's helping the kid at the first
two points where the system's breaking
down. From that point, the body because
it's not handling energy correctly
has to depend on stress hormone. Stress
hormone is like an emergency source of
energy. Now, the body's not able to
handle energy correctly. You're going to
low blood sugar, high blood sugar. Cells
aren't getting nutrient. And by the way,
when cells stop listening to insulin,
not only does this impact how sugar is
handled,
but insulin is important for how
nutrients get into cells.
So now the cell's not getting the
vitamins, it's not getting the minerals,
it's not getting the fatty acids that it
needs. You can see how this is all
tumbling out of control and it all
starts with the digestive system. And so
now you've got a kid who's he doesn't
have the energy that he needs. So he's
depend he's going to start to depend on
adrenal energy, cortisol energy, which
is for emergencies. It's fine, but it's
not fine for chronic as a chronic source
of energy or a chronic way to get
energy. And eventually in response to
the uh hypercortisol which is in
response to the hyper to the insulin
resistance and which is in response to
the elevated blood blood sugar and
insulin resistance which is in response
to the or food choices and the digestive
problems and the dispiosis and the and
the formula. Now the body will slow the
thyroid will slow down to kind of
compensate for the speeding up of the of
the biochemical processes under the
control of cortisol. So now you have
hypothyroidism
which leads as I said earlier to more
digestive problems because the thyroid
regulates the digestive system which
leads to more metabolic problems because
the thyroid regulates the metabolic
system which leads to more cortisol
problems which further suppresses
chemistry and and leads to more
hypothyroidism and that's where most
people are. I call that the triangle of
disease. Now to to simplify we don't
even need to talk about the adrenal
thyroid issue. Just to simplify, work on
blood sugar and that includes insulin,
work on food and digestion. It's as
simple as that. And there's nothing your
doctor can do about it. And you don't
need to go to a doctor to be tested and
you don't need allergy testing and blood
sugar testing and thyroid testing. Just
work on the food component and then work
on the uh blood sugar and insulin
component. And interestingly, they're
all food. Blood sugar and insulin is
also food. So it's really all food. And
when you think about it,
our food supply
which has remained relatively stable for
thousands and thousands of years and if
you want to go back far enough for
millions of years in a body that has not
evolved for 2 million years has
completely changed over has completely
turned over in the last 100 years or 130
years. So, if all of human evolution was
a 24-hour clock,
at 1 second to midnight, we completely
change the food supply. And we change
the food supply not only to make the
food less valuable nutritionally, but to
make it more palatable so that it's
irresistible. So, now you've got this
combination of hyper palatable food that
is also nutritionally deficient. Hello.
Of course, you're going to have a
problem. Of course, you're going to have
an epidemic of chronic degenerative
diseases. And it's not medical.
Medicine should be reserved for
emergencies. If you're going to a doctor
cuz you have high blood sugar, you drank
the Kool-Aid.
You're you're barking up the wrong tree.
There's no that it's not their business.
They'll take it because that's how
they're first of all, they make money
off of it, but second of all, that's how
they're trained. But it's not their job.
If you have a digestive problem and you
go to a GI guy, it's not their job. It's
our job. And that's why taking
responsibility becomes so important. But
you're not going to take responsibility
unless you do the number one thing,
which is belief. And that's the triangle
of disease. Digestion, the blood sugar,
the adrenal thyroid complex or the H
they call it the ad they call it the uh
adrenal h or the HPA thyroid axis they
call it. But don't even worry about
that. Digestive system, blood sugar
system, and that includes insulin.
>> Simple as that. Okay.
>> Fantastic. I I want to do just one ad to
that and um ask when you talk about us
eating sugar. There's multiple types of
sugar. There's several fruits.
>> No, there's not. There's not there's not
multiple types of sugar that the body
uses.
>> Okay. There's glucose and there's
fructose.
>> Yeah,
>> that's pretty much it. Fructose and
fructose is a little handled a little
bit differently. Fructose is mostly
handled by the liver,
>> right?
>> So glucose is the real issue. And and to
your point about multiple sugars, it's
not really multiple sugars. It's
multiple foods that contain them.
>> Absolutely. And today we have engineered
foods to be super glucose rich because
glucose hits the body's hot buttons, the
brain's hot buttons. So we can't resist
them. And we'll we're will subsist. You
know, rats will hit the button until
they die in order to get a glucose hit.
And we do the we do the same thing.
Although not as literally, but they put
rats in these machines, you know, where
they hit the little hit the little
switch to get a hit of glucose. they'll
do it until they die. It's it's more
addictive than than drug than heroin.
So, yes, it's a big problem. And here's
where it gets even sneakier. The high
glucose foods are spiked with
excyitotoxins that keep you eating. The
they're non-sugar. They're not they're
chemicals that hit your brain and make
you
addicted to the foods, which is why we
can't stop eating the foods. And it's
not just high sugar foods. It's also
high calorie foods. between high sugar
foods and high calorie foods and
exytotoxins, foods that have been
engineered to make them irresistible.
It's not necessarily our fault. We're
being manipulated. It's our fault in the
sense that we can do something about it.
Only we can do something about it. But
it's not our fault in the sense that if
we don't know, we're being manipulated
against our will or against our or in a
surreptitious sneaky kind of way. Um and
then another thing is when we think of
sugar, you know, obviously cake and pie
and candy that you know that's sugar,
dessert kind of foods, but pasta is
sugar, beans are sugar, potatoes are
sugar, rice is sugar, any starchy foods
will break down into sugar, burritos are
sugar, pizza sugar. So there's there's
sugar in hidden places. You may think,
"Oh, I don't like sweets. I don't eat a
lot of desserts." But if you're eating
bagels, that's sugar. You're eating um
you know, pizza, that's sugar. If you're
eating bread, that's sugar. And I'm not
saying zero tolerance.
And a couple things. First of all, not
saying zero tolerance. You got to have
some sugar and it's not the end of the
world to eat sugar. Your body can
adjust.
So don't go into zero tolerance. But
most importantly, don't go into guilt.
Don't go into this idea, I'm a bad
person. I have no willpower. Punishing
yourself or guilting your friends, your
neighbors, your family, or your kids or
your husband, your wife. Nobody wants to
hear it.
Nobody wants to hear about what they're
eating unless they ask you. So, you
don't want to go into guilt. You don't
want to guilt trip anybody. You want to
guilt trip yourself. And um
you don't want to underestimate the
power and the the the uh the tyranny of
the chemistry over our bodies. Believe
number one. Don't guilt trip anybody.
You don't have to have zero tolerance.
There's a if you get to control it. The
less you eat, the better off you'll be.
Every study that's ever been done on
longevity shows that the lower your
caloric intake, the longer your life.
What does a calorie mean? What what does
the word calorie mean? Calor. Heat.
Right.
>> What is inflammation? Flame. Right in
the middle of the word flame.
>> The cardinal one of the cardinal signs
of of inflammation is heat. Calories are
by definition inflammatory. There's a
phenomenon known as postprandial
inflammation. Prandial means eating.
Postrandially,
our body goes into inflammatory
mode, which actually makes sense when
you think about it because you now put
the enemy in the body. So, the defense
system kicks in. The less you eat, the
less the defense system will kick in. If
you already got too much defense, uh,
too much of a defense system from
toxicity or from from malnourishment or
from hypoxia, low blood oxygen. Now you
put food in, you could throw it over to
o you could throw the inflammatory
system over the edge. That's why fasting
is so helpful and that's why it's known
as the perfect medicine is fasting.
>> Got it.
>> And again, you have to eat eventually,
but the less you eat, the longer you
live.
>> Thank you.
>> Many questions are here. I'll turn it
over to Ruth Ellen to uh control the
process.
>> Okay, Ruth Ellen. Control the process.
>> Control. Thank you. Um, did you have
more questions, Mary? I just want to
make sure we have a question in the chat
here um from somebody and we're running
out of time.
>> Yeah, there's many. So, I'll let you uh
I'll let you manage that.
>> Okay. Thank you. Thank you.
>> All right. So, Haddie, would you like to
unmute yourself, please?
>> Ash, can you hear me? Okay.
>> Yes.
>> Awesome. Pharmacist Ben.
This has been a thorough discussion.
It's been awesome. I have um I have my
niece on the she couldn't connect to the
form, but
>> I have her on my other line and she
wants
>> Is she listen? Is she listening?
>> She is listening.
>> Okay, good. and her doctor recently told
her that she had to go on dialysis
immediately
and I explained to her that
that not necessarily the case but I
wanted her to talk to you.
>> Okay. So So yeah, let's talk about
diialysis. Kidney disease is an
epidemic.
>> Are you hearing
>> and the main reason?
>> No. What are you saying?
>> Okay. I'm just He's getting ready to
talk to you about that.
>> Kidney disease is an epidemic. It should
always be regarded as a blood sugar
issue. Now you can have kidney disease
when you have lead poisoning for example
or other toxicities because the kidneys
are made up of very very I say tiny but
that doesn't even you know that doesn't
even express it microscopically
invisible
vessels that you can't see with your eye
>> much thinner than a human hair. And
these blood vessels function as filters
for the blood. The blood goes through
and certain things come out like for
example minerals come out and other
things go through the the kidney is the
is the filter and you have two of them
for good reason because you need
redundancy
and in fact the many miles of blood
vessels in invisible blood vessels in
the kidneys are themselves redundant to
the point where you could have 70% of
your kidneys dysfunctional and you won't
even know it. There's so much redundancy
in there. So by the time you need
dialysis, you're at like 90%. Or 85%.
The kidney's not working. There's a lot
of damage there. So at this point, it's
very likely you do need dialysis. But
immediately, if you don't want to be
sitting in a dialysis chair for four
hours, every couple of days, or however
long you're going to be there,
immediately
get your blood sugar under control.
immediately today and in when I say get
your blood sugar under control I mean
from two directions number one what
you're eating obviously but number two
how you're the supplements you're using
to address the sugar that's in there so
get on the blood sugar pack get on the
the mineral t or the the cherry ms or
the or the beyond tangy tangerine which
is part of the blood sugar pack the
ultimate nascin the fucoid z uh osteomag
anything you could do to support blood
sugar uh blood sugar control and insulin
resistance. And there's a ton of
nutritional supplements you could use.
So, couple couple things to sum that up.
Number one, you treat it like a blood
sugar problem. And I'm Haddie, your
friend or your cousin or whoever this
person is knows good and well they got
blood sugar problems and they got other
signs of metabolic syndrome. I guarantee
not because I'm psychic because I'm
telling you how the system works. had to
ask her weight issues, heart issues,
vascular issue or high blood pressure,
digestive issues, bile issues,
reproductive issues. Had to ask her.
>> Are you here?
>> High blood pressure.
>> Oh, surprise.
>> You guys,
what's your friend's name? Your cousin.
What is she?
>> She's my niece. Crystal. Crystal, do you
hear what did you hear what I said? It's
a syndrome. It's all together. You can't
just focus on the kidneys. Unless you're
a doctor, then you'll focus on the
kidneys. You got to focus on everything
that leads to the kidney. It's the root,
not the fruit. You got to get to the
soil. And that's going to be in the
blood sugar system primarily, but also
the digestive system. Get all and and
Hattie can help you. We can all help you
do everything you need to do to
stabilize your blood sugar. Patch up
your gut. Uh, and there's a zillion
strategies for that. And believe this
can be done. I don't know how old you
are, ma'am, Crystal, but this can be
done. The older you are, the harder it
is, obviously, but it's no matter what,
it can be done. The body can turn on a
dime. Don't let anybody tell you that
you're doomed. That's the That's the
worst thing is when the physicians tell
you, "Well, you got to do this or else
you're going to die." Because we believe
them. You can reverse this. You may need
the dialysis right now. I don't know. I
don't know the answer to that. Um, so I
can't answer, but I can tell you that um
that this is something that you can
control, but you got to focus on the
soil, the root, not the fruit. Does that
help, Hattie?
>> Yes, sir. Thank you so very much.
>> Okay. Thank you, Hattie.
>> Says thank you, too.
>> Thank you, Hattie. And um we're grateful
for you. Okay. And then we have another
person on YouTube who has a client that
has cysts in her breast.
>> Okay, sis. Let's let's talk about cysts
in the breast.
>> Okay, but um she she wants to know what
you would give her besides the 90 and
extra E and selenium. So she's on the
90.
>> That's plenty. The problem is not I mean
you need the 90, but and you need the
ultimate EFAs. I'd probably throw in the
F point Z. I'd probably throw in the
ultimate selenium. I don't know if
they're part of the pack. These are all
ways that you can process help your body
process estrogen. Usually when you and
and the reason for cysts are insulin and
estrogen. Those are the two main
culprits in the growth of growth of
cysts. Insulin and estrogen and they're
related. So work on your blood sugar.
The whole thing with metabolic syndrome.
Cysts are part of the metabolic syndrome
um constellation of symptoms. So more
than likely this person is dealing with
metabolic syndrome. Treat yourself. Use
use all the blood sugar strategies. I
don't care if they diagnose you as a
diabetic or not. treat yourself like a
diabetic. Then there's the estrogen
component. Estrogen is broken down in
the intestine and also involves it also
involves estrogen processing also
involves the liver and the gallbladder.
All digestive structures work on the
digestive system and stay away from the
bad fats, the processed fats, the seed
oils, the distorted cooking your fats,
distorting the fats.
Breasts, the breasts are fatty tissue.
cyst represent an imbalance in how fat
or an imbalance in in fats and a
disturbance in how fats are processed.
Treat yourself like a diabetic. Use all
the d and the healthy blood sugar pack
etc. Use all the digestive support
strategies that we talk about on the
program and stay away from problem foods
that foods that are problems for you as
well as general problem foods like like
the seed oils and the processed oils.
And that's how you deal with cyst. Now
you may I don't know how old this person
is. I don't know what other problems she
has. So, I'm giving you just general
ideas here. I'd have to talk to this
person to get some more specifics to
really hone in on on a protocol, but
generally speaking, you want to focus on
you want to treat it as an insulin issue
and an estrogen issue.
>> Okay. Thank you. All right. We have uh
four minutes. Do you have time for one
more question?
>> Yeah, let's do let's do one more,
Marilyn.
>> Oops, I accidentally muted you. I was
meant to spotlight you. So, just we only
have a couple minutes, Marilyn. Okay.
>> Fantastic. I just want to say this is
what we're up against. I have a client
who's been taking supplements for years.
Very smart individual, math teacher, um,
pre-calculus till she was like 67, she
taught. Anyway, she says to me, Kevin
Ree, he's a Young Jegeevity distributor.
She just says, um, he uses Young Jevity
products in his membership and push it
and publishes all of his clients
results, which I read every day. She
says, "I have never seen or heard anyone
say that their diabetes or addictions
were reversed or that they dropped a
significant amount of weight." Okay.
Then she goes on to say, "I've spent
thousands of dollars on top quality
supplements throughout my life, yet I
still developed hypothyroidism,
pollen, allergies."
>> Okay, hang on, hang on, hang on, hang
on. What is the purpose of this this
litany? Because this You're saying
you're saying this is smart, but she
doesn't sound very smart. She may know
math. I don't know who this person is.
She might know,
>> but I don't want I don't debate those
kinds of things. I don't talk
>> I'm bringing this up to you is how would
you do a
>> I don't
I don't I say goodbye. I say go to your
doctor. You're not here for us. Go to
your doctor because your doctor
obviously can help you. Whatever. I
don't argue. You don't argue with people
unless she comes to me and says, "Look,
I'm sorry. I don't really understand
this." But if she says, "I'm really
smart and I know how to supplement and I
taught math and I I know calculus."
Fine. We're not talking to her. We're
talking to people who want answers from
us. I don't ever argue with people. I
don't ever debate people. Everybody has
it. Fine. She can. There's plenty of
people who need us. She doesn't need us.
God love her. Jesus loves everybody. The
sign the sun shines on everything. On
every all.
>> You said belief has to be first.
>> You got to believe first. I'm not
interested in debating anybody. So if
you want to come to me with in a
debating posture, well, I shouldn't say
that. I'll debate anybody. But when it
comes to helping them, I'm not
interested in having them argue with me
when I'm trying to help them. That's not
I don't care. So you come, if you were
interested, I'm happy to help. There's
nobody I'll ever turn down. But when you
say somebody, I'm really smart because
I've been supplementing a long time. And
to say the the ludicrousness of saying
I've never seen anybody lose weight,
that's just that's just mind-numbing to
me. And I don't even want to go there.
>> It was to me, too. And that's why I had
to
>> Yeah. So fine. There's plenty of
doctors. There's tons of doctors. She
doesn't need us.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Go and go and sin no more.
>> Are there publications though a lot that
proving that
>> I don't No, I'm not interested in
proving anything. I'm not interest
people. I'm not interested proving
anything. If you want to and that's why
I go to to great pains to show you the
mechanism.
I don't ever say do this, do that. Do
you ever hear me say just take this,
take that? I'm always telling you how it
happens. So for smart people, whether
this person is smart or not, I don't
know. But for smart people, they'll see
the mechanism. They'll see how blood
sugar, how elevated insulin or
hyperinsulinemia, if you will, how it
affects uh weight, how it affects cell
chemistry, how it affects cell
nutrition, how it affects the
inflammatory process. It's it's just
logical. It's sequential. And it happens
as a as a syndrome where one thing leads
to a bunch of a bunch of problems. She
doesn't believe it. I'm not going to I
don't care. That's her business.
Everybody gets entitled to do what they
do. I'll say it again because I love
this image. And then I have to go.
>> Yes.
>> Bugs Bugs Bunny walking the little old
lady across the street and and she
doesn't want to be walked across the
street. So she's hitting him on the head
with her umbrella while he's walking her
across the street. She doesn't want his
help. You don't help people who don't
want to be helped. You know, that's just
a rule. It's, you know, there's a there
there's an old saying, you can't teach
an animal to sing. You're just going to
piss off the animal and it's not going
to work, you know. So, just don't you
don't go get in there. Don't want help.
That's fine. AJ, real quick. Oh, I got
Marilyn on the call here. Marilyn, give
us a couple minutes. We're just
finishing a call. Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> It's Maryanne. And then so just just a
quick uh thing, you know, like you said,
pharmacist man,
>> love it. Love it. Hey, Rod,
>> thank you.
>> We're just talking about you. AJ and I
were just talking about you this
morning.
>> Yeah, we were talking about you. Yeah,
we're talking about the fact that you
got married, Rod. Congratulations.
>> Congratulations, Rod. That's awesome.
>> All right, you guys. I got a bowl.
>> All right. Thank you. Have a great day.
>> Bye.
>> All right. Thank you everybody for
joining us today. Another powerful
episode of Pharmacist Friday with Ben
Fuches at on Daily with Doc and Becca.
Uh if somebody referred you to this
program, please get back with them
because they will be your lead person in
helping you uh do what Ben said to do or
any questions that you have. Uh please
do that. Also, if you have questions and
would like to speak to a health coach,
you can do two things. You can call
855-9493377
and you will be able to contact a health
coach that way on phone or questions at
dailywithdocbecca.com
or no. Yeah, questions at
dailybecca.com.
No, that's not it.
I'm sorry. dailywithdock.com.
>> dailywithdoc. Yeah. No, never mind. The
email is questions dailywithdoc. All
right.
Um
Oh boy, I feel like an idiot right now.
Okay, I got to make fun of myself. I
feel silly. All right, so anyway, um so
we have Marilyn who is Speedy Fingers
and helps do the dictation
and um she types faster than as fast as
people can talk pretty much. And then
she even looks things up and posts them
in there. I don't know how you do it. I
say that every day, but thank you so
much. And then we have Mary who is
helping bring questions in from the
different platforms and helping out on
the Zoom as well. So, thank you so much,
Mary. Then we have Albert who is
the gatekeeper and he lets people in and
um he also answers the phone in the
middle of the night when the rest of us
are sleeping. So if you call in the
middle of the night, you're probably
going to get Albert. Also, we have
Phyllis who is out on the different
platforms, a lot of platforms, and uh
posting and bringing questions in and
she also helps fill in uh she posts some
things that Phyllis does. I mean
Marilyn, I'm rushing that Marilyn
doesn't post. So when Marilyn is asking
a question or something, Phyllis is
filling in. And then we have Rod who is
also out on the different platforms and
uh bringing in questions and commenting.
So thank you for all that you do Rod.
And then of course we have AJ who is the
digital marketing director and he has
helped us get out onto all those
platforms and he helps set things up and
he does a lot of things that um just
there's too many to count.
Yes.
You you guys say that a lot. But there
were tons of platforms before I got
here.
>> This is true.
>> But still, you helped us get on more
platforms.
>> You're right. We were on a lot. So,
uh, anyway, I'm Ruth Ellen Sanchez. I'm
the executive production manager for
Daily with Doc and Becca, and I just do
whatever that entails, whatever it
means, however long it takes, in the
middle of the night, whatever it is. So,
um, and Rebecca, shout out to you
because you helped make all of this
possible.
All right. Um, I think I covered it all.
Uh, this program is for educational
purposes only, not meant to treat,
diagnose, or cure any diseases. I just
need to say that. And, um, be kind
because you don't know what somebody's
going through. And, uh, you want to make
sure just to put out kindness because
the world is going through some major
stuff right now and I can't say enough
about it. And I did put in the YouTube
chat for somebody to email questions
dailywithdoc.com
and put your my name in the uh question
in the subject line because I can help
you with that particular situation. All
right. Um thank you again everybody.
Have a beautiful day and have a great
weekend and we will see you next week.
Thank you. Bye bye.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, Ford postdo
and pathology, naturopathic doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Does and Pathology,
Naturopathic Doctor